The goal of baseball team is to make the playoffs.
The A's approach was to get to the playoffs
by using analytics.
We'll first show how we can predict whether
or not
a team will make the playoffs by knowing how
many games they
won in the regular season.
We will then use linear regression
to predict how many games a team will
win using the difference between runs scored
and runs allowed,
or opponent runs.
We will then use linear regression again
to predict the number of runs a team will
score
using batting statistics, and the number of
runs a team will allow using fielding and
pitching
statistics.
We'll start by figuring out how many games
a team needs
to win to make the playoffs, and then
how many more runs a team needs to score than
their opponent
to win that many games.
So our first question is how many games does
a team
need to win in the regular season
to make it to the playoffs.
In Moneyball, Paul DePodesta reduced the regular
season
to a math problem.
He judged that it would take 95 wins for the
A's to make it
to the playoffs.
Let's see if we can verify this using data.
This graph uses data from all teams and seasons,
from 1996 to 2001.
There is a point on the graph for every team
and season pair.
They are sorted on the x-axis by number of
regular season wins,
and are ordered on the y-axis by team.
The gray points correspond to the teams that
did not
make the playoffs, and the red points
correspond to the teams that did make the
playoffs.
This graph shows us that if a team wins 95
or more games,
or is on the right side of this line,
they almost certainly will make it to the
playoffs.
But if a team wins, say, 85 or more games
then they're likely to make it to the playoffs,
but it's not as certain.
And if a team wins, say, 100 or more games
then
they definitely will make it to the playoffs.
So this graph shows us that if a team wins
95 or more games then
they have a strong chance of making it
to the playoffs, which confirms Paul DePodesta's
claim.
So we know that a team wants to win 95 or
more games.
But how does a team win games?
Well, they score more runs than their opponent
does.
But how many more do they need to score?
The A's calculated that they needed
to score 135 more runs than they allowed
during the regular season to expect to win
95 games.
Let's see if we can verify this using linear
regression in R.
In our R console, let's start by loading our
data.
We'll call it baseball, and use the read.csv
function
to read in the data file, baseball.csv.
We can look at the structure of our data
by using the str function.
This data set includes an observation
for every team and year pair from 1962 to
for all seasons with 162 games.
We have 15 variables in our data set,
including runs scored, RS, runs allowed,
RA, and Wins, W. We also have several other
variables
that we'll use when building models later
on in the lecture.
Since we are confirming the claims made in
Moneyball,
we want to build models using data
Paul DePodesta had in 2002.
So let's start by subsetting our data to only
include
the years before 2002.
We'll call our new data set, moneyball, and
use
the subset function to only take the rows
of baseball
for which year is less than 2002.
We can look at this structure of the data
set, moneyball,
by using the str function again.
Now, we have 902 observations of the same
15 variables.
So we want to build a linear regression equation
to predict wins using the difference between
runs
scored and runs allowed.
To make this a little easier, let's
start by creating a new variable called, RD,
for run difference,
and set that equal to runs scored minus runs
allowed.
If we look at the structure of our data again,
we can see that we have a new variable called,
RD.
So let's build a linear regression equation
using the lm function to predict wins
with RD as our independent variable,
and using the data set, moneyball.
We can look at the summary of our linear regression
equation,
and we can see that both the intercept
and our independent variable, RD, are highly
significant.
And our R-squared is 0.88.
So we have a strong model to predict wins
using the difference between runs scored and
runs allowed.
Now, let's see if we can use this model
to confirm the claim made in Moneyball that
a team needs
to score at least 135 more runs than they
allow to win at least 95 games.
Our regression equation is wins equals
80.8814, our intercept term, plus the coefficient
for run
difference, 0.1058, times run difference,
or RD.
We want wins to be greater than or equal to
95.
This will be true if and only if our regression
equation is also
greater than or equal to 95.
By manipulating this equation, we
can see that this will be true if
and only if run difference, or RD,
is greater than or equal to 95 minus the intercept
term,
88.8814, divided by 0.1058, which is equal
to 133.4.
So this tells us that if the run difference
of a team
is greater than or equal to 133.4
then they will win at least 95 games,
according to our regression equation.
This is very close to the claim made in Moneyball
that a team needs to score at least 135 more
runs than they
allow to win at least 95 games.
So using linear regression and data,
we were able to verify the claim made
by Paul DePodesta in Moneyball.